this is Tim oliphan on uh Conan O'Brien
needs a friend
and fall is here and then the Bell no no
no no no no
which might
this podcast don't tell Conan I said
that
but uh that I'm a big fan of that Jack
White song oh yeah technically that's a
white stripe song I'm not sure yeah it
probably is I'm gonna say it's if only
we had little devices in our pockets
where we could look that up I'm a fan of
a um The White Stripes in the Jack White
and the Conor O'Brien yeah he doesn't I
mean he might need more friends well
that's why he started the podcast that's
what it says that's a that's a that's a
weigh-in yeah it is a weigh-in it's just
a weigh-in but the premise was that he
has these friends that he sees in a like
Hollywood friends that he sees in a in a
professional setting but rarely does he
socialize with them outside of the
professional setting like rarely does he
get dinner with them
hang out
in a real social way but I think you're
an exception to the sort of premise of
the show you know what you might be
right and as you say it I actually don't
know I feel like he's more social than
he does he I feel like he gets out more
often than we he's very well liked yes
and uh I've been to his home and and
when he's had people over and um and
people love them
I I think it's a gimmick yeah it's a
gimmick I think it's a yeah it is a
gimmick
um the theme song works really well with
this but the Theme Song Remains really
well and you know you got to come up
with something here's the point this is
uh
I've I've uh I've listened to the show
when he's had very very special guests
people that mean a lot to him and he
just does away with the intro yeah like
a former First Lady Michelle Obama
something like that he won't do the
intro did he uh and even speaking of uh
Mr White I don't did he do an intro on
why I think he just went right into the
show that's that's possible too it's
possible yeah it's it's it's special
guest and also if it goes really if it
goes really long sometimes we'll say
let's just skip the intro altogether
okay I did one of those two things I'm
one of those two I went long but I'm not
so yeah because I asked him about the
intro that that's like a 10 minute intro
yeah usually if you have five ten
minutes five ten minutes yeah but no but
you are a really special guest you were
one of the first guests I think you came
on a few months after the show launched
okay uh and there has been a clam ring
to get you back and it's it took it took
a long time it's so nice to hear I mean
not genuinely I
um none of it makes sense to me that's
true it's the I think you were the first
guest to to come in and sort of like
Break The Rules a little bit and make it
create a little bit of chaos but here's
the deal I'm trying I was thinking today
that um as much as I've enjoyed the uh
the the podcast the Preamble I've
decided that that perhaps there should
be a preamble before the intro before
intro to the intro
that's what this is right now we don't
even have we have none of the actual
hosts of the show that's my point it's
only a part of the show either I know so
this is I if this makes it on on uh
on the what do we call this on the
podcast on the podcast I was about to
say it makes it on the air yeah well
this is an old person well we'll see
because goalie's not here
squirley will receive this audio and
he'll have to figure out what how to
what to make of it oh really to do with
it yeah so we're that's who we're right
now we're gonna send this to Matt this
is like an audition yeah I'm auditioning
for something yeah ah so you can speak
directly to Gourley ah okay
hey bud hey Tim
there you go it's good to see you thanks
for being here oh it's great to be here
at a later date in a different place I
appreciate you being here for me
um he is a super fan of yours too we he
and I talk about that doesn't make up
for the fact that he's not here no no it
doesn't No in fact it makes it even a
little more it's hurtful a little more
hurtful why isn't here is a budget thing
is that what Conan's having the meeting
yeah Conan had a meeting was serious
it wouldn't fly the other two out huh
they're coming out but they're coming
out uh Wednesday
we've got these shows at the end of the
week that's right and then that's the
other thing he mentioned something about
what's he doing at the Beacon yeah he's
doing a live show uh two live shows
Thursday and Friday night really live
podcast who's it who's a who's on the
live podcast we can say it now because
this will Air after they happen but
um
Stephen Colbert and Tracy Morgan I bet
that'll be good I'm gonna guess I'm
gonna guess they went over really well
I think we'll see but I'm confident
they're good guests they're really
they're home run guests that's good live
gas and at the Beacon and they're gonna
do their thing yeah all right I feel
like this is not gonna go over gorilla
might just cut it out completely you
might have to cut it out completely
because it feels like I should have to
say something like an anecdote to to uh
O'Brien yeah let me tell you about
O'Brien
first of all I'll tell you my history of
uh Conan O'Brien
way back when in the 90s when he was
doing a show here in New York
I went on his show as a guest
he doesn't remember that I barely
remember it I was so nervous I I was the
most nerve-wracking thing I remember
being going out there I remember his
lips moving and then I was like I I was
it was just I just like okay I'm gonna
continue with my story was it one of
your first Lane Bert it was my very
first late night talk show appearance
and it was so nerve-wracking and I have
to confess I am such a fan and am such a
fan of a great talk show and a great
talk show appearance
and I was just the whole thing was I
think I was almost late
it was like breaking out I was nervous
as all get out it's like late 90s not
even that young
and I did not do another talk show for
years after that because I was like no
no
I'm not ready and then anyway so then
you I think maybe might have been close
to 10 years before I went on his show
out in LA
and um
I just had a ball it's but you've it's
crazy to hear because you seem like such
a natural doing it and so
uh relaxed actually from a viewer's
perspective you just you seem so natural
I appreciate you saying so I I tell you
the whole thing you know the
everything about Show Business early on
was just confusing and nerve-wracking
and just like
um oh just a nightmare I remember the
first time the first and only time I
went on Letterman and uh it's like just
a year or so before he retired as I
remember and I remember
being in my house and I was looking at
great Letterman guests like I was
looking at all these guests just that
thing of trying to remind myself like
what makes him laugh you know just
trying to think about
what makes a great appearance on
Letterman so I'm watching all the usuals
and my wife comes in and says what are
you doing and I say I'm just watching
um
clips from great Letterman guests and
and she looks over my shoulder and she's
like that's like Martin Short and it's
like yeah he's a really you know and
then it's like and that's like Bill
Murray and I'm like yeah exactly she
goes what are you doing and I was like
what do you mean he's like
when those people come on his show he's
super excited
he doesn't give a about you like he
doesn't this is true it's turned into a
letterman story Conan can't get enough
of Letterman's stories he'll appreciate
that I'm starting this podcast with a
letterman story
and I realized she's so right I realize
I'm preparing like I'm looking at these
guys and what they're doing and how he's
reacting and then she's like yeah but
she's she's totally right so I think to
myself okay she's got a point here you
know
um
so I I Googled I I thought of an actor
who was in a similar spot this was I
think first or second season of
Justified we'd just come out I think
we've done a season
and so I looked up actors that I thought
were more or less in my position you
know at that time or or looked up them
when they were at that position like Jon
Hamm God bless him good dude like right
when Mad Men came out yeah like okay
like that's a similar spot
I I watched clips of those actors on
Letterman
and he did not give
and I was like oh my God
I got so right right
yeah and it just that was probably a
little bit of a relief though to see I
don't know if it was a relief but it was
certainly uh uh of value what you don't
prepare for that first moment when he's
just like my next guest is so and so and
he has no idea who that person is you
know you just immediately are going to
the like
um and I think maybe there was something
similar like that when I when you know
going on the talk show the first time
going on O'Brien which was like
you know you just you imagine that you
think of your anecdotes and they're
funny and whatever whatever and then you
just don't realize that first moment
when you just like walk out there and
you and there's it's like every show
business experience I ever had when
you're like you know I remember going on
my first set and just like what's all
this colored tape on the ground you know
like I just didn't know what any of
those things were what do you think made
it easier is it just the Reps is it just
doing it multiple times or getting more
comfortable than your own skin as a
actor and someone being interviewed
there's something to be said about not
giving a you know if you can get to
yourself to a place where it's all just
a joke and then there's the other thing
which is uh don't tell Conan he's really
good at what he does yeah so he's he is
exceptionally good at what he does and
um
it he just makes it look easy he makes
you he carries you at times he fills in
areas and um
just makes it so smooth I mean so many
times I realize it's like a sleight of
hand he makes me come off really well
yeah so he's really good you know
he may not have a lot of friends but
he's you know he's he's gone really good
at what he does and I think that's uh if
nothing else that's um
that's the takeaway here should we go to
the intro
oh now what I'd like to do
is go from this intro to his intro all
right sounds great see you later
everybody